Here's a short venture into the failed ideas
that are floating around to fight Corona virus.
Louisiana is a state that is really suffering
with coronavirus.
Louisiana has the fourth most cases per capita.
Louisiana has the seventh most deaths per
capita.
But most importantly, the disease is quickly
returning to Louisiana, where from early June
through yesterday, cases have gone higher
and higher.
Louisiana has more people actively infected
today than at any previous point during the
pandemic.
So what is Louisiana Governor John Bel Edwards
do?
Well, he obviously calls for three days of
prayer and fasting.
Now, Belle Edwards is a Democrat, by the way.
He says pastors reached out to him and said,
you know, you should maybe support fasting
and prayer to deal with the virus.
So he's going to be calling for it statewide.
Take a look at this.
I do want to let you all know that that every
couple, three weeks I have a the opportunity
to have a conference call with hundreds of
pastors across the state of Louisiana.
And last week, we had such a call and received
a request.
And I'm happy to honor today.
And and it's I know it's a little bit unusual,
but but I think it's it's something that it's
important, at least for me and those people
on the call and many other Louisianans.
So I'm going to call for three days of fasting
and prayer for our state for July 20th through
the 22nd.
So that's the 20th to 21st, the 22nd.
This will be the spiritual diet and exercise
that I, as a Catholic Christian believes very
important anyway.
So we'll be doing lunch, fasting for those
three days and certainly praying as well,
praying for the
people of Louisiana, praying for those who
are sick, praying for those who care for those
who are sick, and certainly praying for the
families of those who have passed on.
You know, he he is right when he says it's
unusual.
That started yesterday, by the way, July 20th,
the fasting and prayer supposed to be yesterday,
today and tomorrow.
Now, as he Matmata said, Hemant Hemant meant
said in a blog post, what Bel Edwards does
in his spare time is really his business.
But what pastors want him to do should be
irrelevant from the standpoint of public announcements
as the secular governor of the state of Louisiana.
Now, I don't mean personally a religious.
I mean that the governorship itself should
be secular, separated from religion.
There is no reason to tell people of the state
to do a religious ritual to fight a virus.
We know what he should be calling for.
We know what needs to be done.
Everybody should be wearing a mask, which
he did say in his defense.
No large group gatherings
mostly stay home, certainly no indoor dining.
We know what to do.
And the mask part.
He did say, but he's calling for prayer and
fasting.
And, you know, some people are defending this
by saying he said this is it.
Non-denominational, right.
Skip lunch and and pray regardless of.
Of your denomination.
What about people who aren't religious?
This is still a government actor who is supposed
to be separate from the church establishing
a religious act.
I mean, prayer is a religious act over non
religion.
And it's another example of of this.
You know, we've tried nothing and we're out
of ideas.
I mean, he's already going to prayer and fasting.
And it's a Democratic governor, not a Republican.
This is not about political party for me.
Mostly this type of stuff is in the Republican
Party.
But here's an example of it from the Democratic
side.
This is certainly a conservative Democrat.
Don't be confused.
But still, this is a Democrat.
And it reminds me of the situation in Mississippi.
Actually, we've talked about Mississippi.
Mississippi is tragically suffering and has
been for decades in the United States.
And yet they're talking and doing nonsense.
In Mississippi, it was.
Well, how can we block black voters from from
voting or how can we make sure that more real
Mississippians register because the blacks
are really registering to vote.
Meanwhile, Mississippi is almost dead last
or dead last in health care, education, et
cetera, et cetera.
Louisiana is one of the most ravaged states
by most indicators.
Louisiana's forty fifth in health care.
Forty eighth in education.
Forty ninth in economic growth.
Forty eighth in infrastructure.
Fiftieth in dealing with climate change.
It's a disaster in Louisiana.
And then you look over and how are they dealing
with Corona virus?
Well, the governor suggests skipping lunch
and praying.
Now, someone wrote to me something that that
is interesting, which is could this be indirectly
brilliant?
In other words, Bel Edwards could be appealing
to religiosity by saying fast during lunch.
Lunch is when a lot of folks go out, especially
if they're working, maybe by saying skip lunch.
He's keeping people out of restaurants and
it's actually going to stop the spread.
I don't know.
It's an interesting question.
It's certainly the most charitable interpretation
of fast and pray to stop the virus.
But that's not really what what this is about.
This is not about reverse engineering, some
way in which a call for fasting and prayer
might connect to better health outcomes with
Corona virus.
This is a governor, a public elected official.
He has no place suggesting religious prayer
and fasting on the say
so of Christian pastors as a solution for
a public health crisis.
And again, look at how poorly things are going
in Louisiana.
We have to ask whether these things are connected.
We're going to have more of about this on
the David Pakman show, Instagram page.
Make sure you are following us there at David
Pakman show.
And while you're on your Instagram app, follow
me at Davidge Dot Patman.
We'll take a quick break.
We do have tragic news to discuss.
Coming up after the interview, and I hope
you'll be with me at the end